eb for folks who don't know take 30
seconds or a minute tell us your
background
well i i put together
a kind of a career in the gold business
almost by accident i mean when i
discovered gold 20 years ago or so i was
immediately fascinated i mean you pick
up one of these coins and wait a minute
why is it so heavy like you guys were
saying the bar so check this out yeah
that was actually the wealthiest i've
ever been in my life holding that bar in
my hand this is a this is a strange
thing and then then you realize that
that this comes out of the earth i mean
it takes two or three thousand pounds of
dirt to
to process to make this one coin you
know like two or three thousand thousand
yeah yeah i mean a ton a ton of gold
will give you like three grams a ton of
dirt would give you like three grams of
gold and so when i saw that i mean i was
fascinated and then
your company finds gold and the stock
goes up you know ten times
and that caught my attention and i said
i gotta figure out how what do you mean
company finds gold yeah they're looking
at times yeah like say they say mining
they're looking for gold okay so they're
looking for gold and they go out and
they they find it and they say we found
a gold mine and their stock goes crazy
and you get kind of gold fever you know
there's shows you watch deadwood or some
show about this it's real you know and
so i figured that out and then i got
into that business and and then i
realized that that's a bad business
because most people don't find gold you
know just like most people's crypto coin
doesn't go up uh and so
anyway so i discovered the the royalty
business and that's what the book is
really about the war against your wealth
and how to win it you know is we are in
a war against against our efforts to
build wealth you know we're under attack
and you guys know that and so i
discovered the royalty business where
all my money is and and so we've created
these long-term royalties on various
different types of assets and uh it's a
business i'm enthusiastic about so i
wrote the whole book so that everyone
can understand that and and so we look
to take a royalty on the gold output
from a mine you know which is very
different you don't pay for any you can
have strikes uh you can have floods you
can all these things happen we don't pay
for any of that you know it's just a
carried interest
in the in the mind so that's how my
career kind of evolved and here we are
today with
outright craziness in the world right
yeah we want to get into that crazy part
who would have predicted all these
things yeah 20 years ago how do we know
this is real how do we know when you
when you hold a gold coin like that how
do you know it's real i don't know so
the best way to do the i like coins
because they're very hard to fake so
like nobody's gonna really nobody's
gonna really put in the time and the
effort you know and you put one coin on
your finger and you
kind of hit it together you can hear
this sound it's very unique sound that
it makes it's called the ping test you
know if you go into a to a pawn shop the
first thing they'll do is they'll ping
the coins together and they'll listen
for that unique sound problem with the
bars is that a couple years ago the
chinese were putting tungsten cores in
the bar so it has a similar weight to
gold and then they were putting gold in
the outside that goes all the way back
to the roman empire when they tried
exactly exactly right so are you saying
the chinese can't be trusted whether
when it comes to that
but they can be they can be because the
chinese are very intense about gold so
the chinese they don't let any gold
leave the country they're the biggest
producer in the world of gold so but
they don't let any gold that they
produce leave the country why is that
what's their argument
they want it in country they want gold
so whereas americans they produce gold
in nevada and just leaves the country
you know the the chinese are like no no
no no why though why do they want it
they see it as real wealth so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]